pour l'abbé thierry laurent curé de la
paroisse saint roch dans le 1er
arrondissement de paris voir son église
vide
en ces temps de célébration est un
véritable crève coeur dans notre foi
dans la dimension spirituelle de notre
être on est très meurtrie de ne pas
pouvoir se rassembler parce que c'est
quand même c'est une chose qui est
extrêmement important pour nous les
chrétiens son nom parmi des groupes
assez rare qui se rassemblent en tout
cas les croyants se rassemblent très
régulièrement notamment le dimanche
et donc voilà les 600 paroissiens qui
fréquentent les différentes messes de la
paroisse dimanche
là on sont privés confinement oblige
depuis le 15 mars
les offices se déroule à huis clos et
sont retransmis sur les réseaux sociaux
alors c'est un pis-aller je suis pas
super content de diffusion par internet
je suis content de d'avoir quand même ça
internet un moyen pourtant devenu
indispensable pour garder le lien avec
les paroissiens
il ya des informations voilà ça c'est la
story pour dire ce qui se passe alors
dire le samedi saint ses 18 heures et 20
heures
il y a mais homélie cette année à défaut
de pouvoir se rendre à l'église pour
célébrer pâques ce paroissiens de saint
roch a suivi la messe sur internet avec
toute sa famille durée ce qui s'est
passé ces émotions des changements
cette année c'est une redécouverte de la
vraie fête quand on n'a plus le droit de
courir qu'on a plus loin de partir faire
des achats consommés et qu'on se
recentre sur l'essentiel
c'est une formidable redécouverte un
instant de confinement mais on peut
remercier sur le fait que notre famille
va bien
la santé la queue il ya encore quelques
chocolats et on peut encore un repas les
enfants ils s'adaptent ils ont joué le
jeu dans la préparation du repas dans le
suivi de la messe en virtuel malgré la
déception de ne pouvoir célébrer comme
le veut la tradition
nicolas veut voir le positif là
forcément une certaine frustration est
certaine tristesse de ne pas pouvoir
tout partagé mais quand on pense à nos
grands-parents qu'ont vécu les choses
bien pires que ce qu'on est en train de
vivre quand on pense à certains peuples
qui vivent des guerres qui vivent des
choses bien pires que ce qu'on vit on
essaye d'être positif des populations
qui célèbre s'est fait dans un contexte
plus hostiles à l'image des chrétiens
d'orient auquel le père sa mère nassif
un prêtre maronite originaire du liban
si un tout particulièrement à rendre
hommage en dehors du liban des reculs
des lésions à l'ab qui va transmettre en
direct du cld sont uniques créés
viennent malheureusement et des grands
suivent un peu sur internet 6 atteint
pays accepte vous savez vivre jésus
cessé en douce et pas seulement dans les
grands cette relation par exemple maman
quand je lui appelé souhaiter joyeuses
par arrêter toute la journée
koné souffre la division aura des
émissions de briller cette année de ma
vie je n'ai jamais fait t'es pas tout
après ce confinement et quand la vie
voir revenir
comme d'habitude cette intensité de
prière dans les maisons et dans des
familles enfin je lis beaucoup de casse
revenir à l'essentiel renouer avec le
sens sacré de pâques
c'est ce que veulent retenir les
chrétiens de cette situation inédite